nadège bonjour les enfants ont donc fait
leur rentrée ce matin au pont de route
est en ordre dispersé surtout en
ile-de-france département classé rouge
sur la carte du coc vite 19
weeds aura un retour sur les bancs de
l'école pour les élèves de
levallois-perret les élèves de grande
section de cp de cm2 retrouve
aujourd'hui le chemin des classes
ils seront 15 maximum par classe après
huit semaines de confinement c'est un
soulagement autant pour les enfants que
pour les parents qui ont décidé de
réintégrer leurs enfants à l'école je
suis confiante non j'ai pas peur dans
tous les cas il faut qu'on continue à
vivre et moi mais l'hôpital a besoin de
moi mes patients moi j'ai besoin aussi
de travailler et d'être de participer je
peux pas m'enfermer chez moi j'ai c'est
mon devoir aussi j'ai pas trop
d'inquiétude puisque le coup vie touche
pas tellement les enfants juste pour
nous mais où on l'aura bien briefé
comment protéger les autres voilà moi ça
va faire du bien un peu quand on descend
prendre l'air je trouve que c'est bien
qu'ils retournent à l'école soulagé je
sais pas on verra comment ça se passe
c'est parce que les règles sont
respectées
si on verra bien comment ça évolue je
n'aime pas trop m'approcher de mes
copains
je les touche pas on a hésité on savait
pas trop comment se positionner puis
l'école nous a bien rassuré par rapport
à ceux qui mettaient en place donc voilà
on leur fait confiance et plan vient et
pour pour l'école je suis pas très
inquiet tombé là c'est qu'on n'est pas
encore à rentrer donc il faut qu'on
attende un petit peu mais je pense que
ça devrait aller côté sécurité sanitaire
la mairie de levallois-perret estime
avoir pris toutes les mesures est
nécessaire respect d'une distance d'un
mètre entre chaque élève lavage régulier
des mains des infections quotidienne du
matériel je vous propose d'écouter le
maire de la ville de levallois-perret
d'un grand soulagement de voir que tout
s'est bien passé
pratiquement tous les enfants sont
rentrés et c'est un grand succès on
l'avait décidé très tôt et c'est le seul
domaine où l'état a pris la main d'une
manière compliquée mais sans doute
indispensable et on a respecté à la
lettre le protocole que l'éducation
nationale à préparer
quand on voit la tête des enfants le
sourire la joie qu'ils ont de se
retrouver de jouer sur les petits trek
nous nous prenons comme des traits de
confinement on n'a pas le droit
d'avancer ils jouent à la marelle dessus
le sourire quand ils retrouvent leurs
enseignants
c'est ce qu'on vous fait le plus chaud
au coeur a non les enfants pour eux il
ya aucune difficulté avec un nombre
réduit d'élèves et des niveaux de classe
toujours fermé
l'enseignement à distance est toujours
très important dispositif exceptionnel
et qui pourrait bien se maintenir à la
rentrée de septembre d'après le
ministère de l'éducation nationale 6 et
bien la situation ne s'améliore pas
nadège abderrazak heures en direct donc
de levallois-perret merci pour toutes
ces précisions